In our last session, we built our first
MLP. We saw that a simple shallow MLP
works fine, but when we try to make it
deeper, we run into the vanishing
gradient problem and our model failed to
learn. In this video, we're going to
build on that knowledge. Our goal is to
construct a robust, flexible, advanced
MLP. We'll introduce several key
techniques used in modern deep learning
such as better weight initialization
and normalization to make our deep
models train efficiently. We'll treat
this as a scientific experiment also
known as an ablation study to see which
components give us the biggest
performance boost. Let's start by
looking at our initial setup here. And
if you notice there is a new one here
utils which is a Python file that I
created and it contains all of the
helper functions that I'm going to use
for plotting running diagnostics and
visualization of the the weights of the
learned weights. Uh this way uh I'm
trying to keep the the main script clean
and we want to focus on the core logic
of the model and the experiment. Okay.
So next uh in the data preparation I
added another step that basically
normalized the input data to have a mean
of zero and a standard deviation of one.
Uh this simple step makes the training
process significantly more stable and
often faster. Normalization creates a a
much smoother optimization landscape and
the optimizer uh can easily navigate
through this well- behaved landscape
compared to before. Moreover, it um
basically ensures all of the input
features are on a comparable scale.
Prevents uh some weights from needing to
learn extremely large or small values.
So with that, let's go ahead and write
our model class. We are going to call it
advanced MLP. It's of course going to
inherit all of the good goodies in an
end module. So this is the init method
that I wrote uh where I added a few
knobs to turn including the choice of
activation uh which allows for an string
input and this string inputs are mapped
to the PyTorch version of it. So
basically for example if we have a
function like get activation it maps the
choice the string to the to the correct
syntax. Here I have two additional
activation that um briefly leaky relu is
a has a small improvement over the
standard relu. If you remember wall
outputs uh are zero for any negative
input. This can lead to uh the dying
neuron phenomena. But leaky relu allows
for a tiny nonzero gradient for negative
inputs. In other word it leaks a little
and helps the the neuron alive. The next
one, Jello, is a basically a Gaussian
error linear unit. Uh it's a smoother uh
more modern alternative to ALU and it
has been recently used in uh advanced
architectures like GPT. Okay, like I
said, I want to make the design
flexible. The reason is we want to do
ablation experiment but also learn
something along the way. So let's uh
introduce this deems list uh which is
basically the components that we are
going to use in each of this hidden
layers. So uh if you notice we have
layers, norms and drops and each one of
them is a module and n module list and
uh notice that I didn't use plain python
list and the reason is this uh n and n
module list is basically uh talks to
pytor directly. If we use a Python list,
it will be invisible to PyTorch. Uh you
can think of it like the the Python list
like a scratch piece of paper that you
write the player name. But uh an and
module list is like an official team
roster for all of these layers, not
players. So, PyTorch as a team manager
uses this roster to correctly find all
of these parameters for the optimizer
and also move them to the correct device
and switch the modes for the layers like
for example dropout or batch norm during
training or eval. So, basically this
gives us a a bunch of tools that we can
use when uh we are building the forward
method. Let's build um uh the hidden
layers. So for i in range of this number
of hidden layers uh we first uh append
the um for each uh index corresponds to
the hidden layer we append the layer
normalization and drops and then we have
a special final layer that is not
following the same logic. uh so we have
to write it separately and this
basically fra framework allows us to to
do that maybe you ask yourself why I
didn't use sequential like before
because our forward pass as you will see
is a is a custom pass and we are going
to apply the layers from three different
different lists of layers norms and
drops in a specific order uh and then
sequential is too simple and has a fixed
data flow however this uh method gives
us the flexibility that we need to build
these custom pipelines and al also it
allows us to to deal with the special
cases like the output layer. So the
output layer doesn't need the
normalization and also dropouts because
normalization will distort the output
scale. Remember that the output is raw
logits that goes to the cross entropy
and the dropout will randomly suppress
some of the prediction which uh we don't
want. Here we initialize the weights
following the choice of the
initialization method. And here we can
write uh two functions uh to map the uh
the choice of initialization method to
the correct syntax in PyTorch. And also
similar thing for the normalization here
if the choice is basically this for
example batch or layer normalization we
map them correctly. So let's write these
two functions. Okay now we can write the
forward method first flatten of course
and then knitting the the toolbox
together to make the pipeline and return
the final there. Okay. So we are going
to use some of some functions from
before like the train one uh epoch and
uh evaluate. Uh we already wrote this.
We are going to just copy and paste and
then we can write the experiments.
So we have different configs here and
for example the the control case control
configuration is where we have the
default initialization method no
normalization and no dropout. The second
will be just adding one type of initial
in initialization here the heiming
initialization and then next we add a
batch norm over the previous one. So
each time we change one setting. Next we
do layer norm and lastly we use we add
the dropout. Okay. So let's let's keep a
tab on the histories. Adding the
criterion and then for each one of these
configuration setting up the model and
the optimizer and zeroing the history
and then we are writing the uh training
loop. Okay.
So populating the history and then print
out some of the result every few apoch.
Okay. So with that we're good to go. We
can do the training. Uh while this is
running um let's just do a fast review
of what we did. We basically saw with
this baseline and we add components one
at a time. We measure the changes in the
performance and at the end we will
choose the best configuration. So while
this is training uh let's uh write um a
code that saves the best model and uh
then we can load it. So first saving
come up with a save path and then save
the best model then of course we can
load uh the model and check if that's
the correct model. So I'm going to just
uh write this with some verification
checks and then after that we can um
look at the uh visualize some of these
tools that we had in to using some of
these tools that we have in utils
including the uh weight visualization uh
like weight distribution and the initial
uh layer weights that is learned uh
basically the filters
uh and uh see if they are telling us
anything. So here is the result. We see
that uh he plus batchnorm is overall the
best model and here is the result of the
visualization and if you notice what we
see here is really random static and the
reason is MLP flattened the image into a
1D vector and basically destroys all
spatial information. doesn't really know
which pixels are next to each other and
this is a clue for us that MLP is not
naturally suited for images. Uh we can
look at the weight distribution. I mean
they look fine really well behaved. So
uh what we did with the initialization
normalization is okay and it's working
but they really don't tell us anything
about what they represent. So um this
gives us this paradox about MLP. Why it
performs well while it really doesn't
seem to be learning anything. It treats
the image as a as a shuffled list of
stock prices. This basically is a hint
for us that it's really not
generalizable. If we for example have a
image of a shirt that is moved in the uh
it's not centered like what we had in
the fashion emnest the entire framework
will collapse in the sense that it
cannot basically predicts that it's the
same shirt. So we need something else
and we can include some of the
assumptions that we have as inductive
bias in this new architecture. So for
example there is an assumption of
locality. The patterns that we found in
an image for example the heel of a boot
can be found in small local regions of
the image. A very important assumption
that the patterns is the same whether
it's in the top left or bottom right of
the image. We call this an translation
invariance. MLP doesn't have either of
them. It basically connects every input
pixel to every neuron. And this way
ignores localology. We will discuss a
new architecture that we are designing
from ground up with these two biases.
And this way it allows the architecture
to learn meaningful spatial features
that look less like noise like what we
saw here. And it can generalize and uh
can be used even with less uh learn
parameters.